hey guys happy tech Tuesday this is a
super informal tech Tuesday because I'm
about to hop on a plane and I was just
doing some last-minute packing and
preparing and one of the most important
things when you're traveling and you
want to actually try to do work
especially edit videos of yourself it
looks a little awkward to the stranger
sitting next to you so I got this the
other day this is not sponsored I've
used this before but then I took it off
and then I lost it along traveling but I
got another one and these are the 3m
privacy filters and you put this on your
computer so that creeps can't be creepin
so you can really only see your computer
from a very specific angle which is
straight on so if anybody's like mama
see what you got going on they're not
gonna be able to see what you got going
on because you're gonna be all like I
have this on my screen it was important
thing that you want to do because I made
this mistake the first time that I use
this I didn't clean my screen so there
were little bubbles bubbles of chunks of
crap on them I use a little bit of this
some all-natural organic glass and
surface cleaner to get it extra clean
scrub-a-dub-dub one mac in the tub
I also have something that I'm gonna
test out on my iPhone that I've never
actually used before but I got it at
Sundance toughs it out and you see my
screen and no you cannot now you don't
see it and now you do so there's two
sides of it which I just I just found
out one is a matte let's try the glossy
I think I like the matte better choose
your side first I think that's the most
important and then you stick little
little stickies on the side this blue
piece is not sticky it's just your
adhesive helper and you just slide it
right down in place at the bottom you
see my screen didn't think you could the
next thing that I have this is why my
house is a disaster I am and I'm in a
hoarders paradise so where's my phone
unless I'm a mess right now cuz I'm a
hoarder
okay where did you go downstairs maybe
be right back where did my mom go well I
didn't find my phone but I found of
juice Oh found my phone
clean now clean it good clean this Apple
just like you should Wow of a glass
privacy reactive touch right it comes
with a little spindle to wipe gently
lift glass from tray a lot harder than I
expected
look you can you can see it peel back
this mask before application Android
like I don't want to mess it up huh it's
not even freakin peg your stuff no still
not even oh it's a freaking air bubble
of course there is gonna drive me crazy
though because it's not perfectly
freakin centered it's pretty cool though
cuz look can't see my phone can't see my
phone what where'd it go
can't see my phone that all got it's
uneven I can't do this I can't live like
this I can't live like this no no no
under there now ah I have to I'm gonna
miss my freakin flight but holy crap
this thing is awesome
other than this ridiculously OCD
annoying process you can color me
the color of impressed um so yeah this
is the alpha glass by OtterBox this is a
3m privacy screen you guys can get these
only Amazon I'll put a link in the
description um there's something under
the era I think I scratched it now I can
go travel and I not be creeped on by the
creeps sitting next to me I'll see guys
later
make sure you like the video cuz
you're supposed to do here happy deck
Tuesday even though is not Tuesday see
you later
right holy moly